so i have a rectangle drawn right over
here and my goal is to split this
rectangle up into smaller equal squares
and the way that i'm going to do that is
by first dividing this rectangle into
two rows
and i should say two equal rows and then
i'm going to divide this rectangle into
five
equal
columns
now i know some of you are saying what
is a row and what is a column
so a row at least my brain thinks about
it as a part of the rectangle that is
going from left to right one way to
think about if i had a bunch of let's
say that these are apples here
and if i wanted to think about
dividing these apples into rows i would
say that this is the first row this is a
second row and that this is a third row
if i were to think in terms of columns i
tend to think of columns as going up
down
and so the columns this would be one
column this would be another column this
would be a third column and this would
be a fourth column so now that we
understand what rows and columns are
let's first think about maybe pause this
video and think about how would you
divide this rectangle into two rows
well the way that i would tackle it is i
would draw a line that goes from left to
right
and there you have it i now have the
rectangle split into one row and now a
second row
now pause the video and you could draw
this if you have a pencil and paper with
you or you could just think about what i
should do how would i now divide this
rectangle into five columns
well what i could do is make
a bunch of lines that go from top to
bottom so that's one column there
this is a second column
this is a third column
this is
a
fourth column and a fifth column so
there you have it i have two rows one
row two rows and i have five columns one
two three four five
now what's interesting is when i split
the rectangle in this way into two rows
and five columns how many equal size
squares did i create
well i've created one two three four
five
six seven eight nine ten equal squares
and that makes sense because each row
has five i have one two three four five
one two three four five and five plus
five is equal to ten another way to
think about it is each column has two
one two one two one two one two one two
and two plus two is four plus two is six
plus two is eight plus two is ten
so that's what two rows splitting the
rectangle into two rows and five columns
gets me it splits it into ten
sections